it's finally here you guys Billy Eilish
joined James Corden for a little carpool
karaoke and it is everything now we're
breaking down the nine most epic moments
from her ride around town with a Late
Late Show host the house should we go
check it out check out the house
starting with this she took fans inside
her childhood home let's go check out
the house let's do it let's get in there
the 18 year old still lives in that
house do you feel like being at home and
still living at home as grounded you in
the last 12 months probably more than I
realized and she showed James her older
brother Phineas's bedroom okay let's do
it let's get in there this is exciting
alright okay so take me through here
bathroom your room this is the belly of
the beast
it's this is Vince's room yep that's the
room where they made her hit album when
we fall asleep where do we go we made
the whole album and the EP even in his
little bedroom in our house no booze no
studio just the bedroom like and it's so
small and check out that door frame yep
those are pencil markings on the wall
seemingly tracking their height epic
mind-blowing moment number six
Billy revealed her brother kind of sort
of manifested her mega success back in
2015 before the two had written a single
song together like what if we made music
together and he goes I'm gonna make you
the biggest pop star in the world and I
was like haha like we like this and get
ready to dive deep into those fields
because Billy's mama joined the combo
and it couldn't be cuter the whole
experience is so cool
easy you know you mean for a while
they'd write these songs and I'd be like
what isn't gonna come out cuz everyone
in the world has to hear and now
everybody hears it and I can't describe
it cuz it's too amazing
I'm not crying you're crying
anyway it was all sweet and sentimental
until Billie whipped out her pet spider
I have a spider you want to see it yes
yes Billy has a freaking pet spider
let me see oh why would you do that why
would you have such a thing cuz he's
cute you know but back to the music I
was 13 recording this on
yes the song makes me emotional coming
in at number three on our list Billy got
teary-eyed listening to her hit ocean
eyes that well just that song like is
the reason that I have the life I have
and she played the first song she ever
wrote when she was six like what what
[Music]
but don't worry guys
Billy may be a super-duper superstar but
she's still the Billy we all know and
love the Billy who stands for Justin
Bieber
she even gosh Tovar meeting the Biebs at
Coachella Justin Bieber who you were
there for when I was there we were at
Coachella yep all Coachella weekend I
was like I can't have to do this show
and Justin Bieber is gonna be there and
I was just standing there and we were
just watching the set and I was rocking
out because I love Ariana and I saw
because I know I know what people look I
know his body language I know how it
stands I know where he wears his pants
so I look over and I just was like and
spit all the lyrics to his hit baby I
had my first love there was nobody that
compared to my baby and nobody came
between us I could ever come above Billy
opened up to et about her love for
Justin back in March when did your love
for the Biebs start um you know what it
started when I was like 12 I believe and
that was like right before he retired
what did you post hers in your room I
did yeah like big ass you have so many
celebrity fans
is anyone sliding into those DMS yet I
mean Bieber did What did he say you have
to say y'all have to see so one day
you'll find out what that was grazie
um the thing that he actually know the
first thing he sent was a screenshot of
a DM I sent him in 2014
stop so he remembered from 20 feet in
remem
but you know who when you follow
somebody you can see everything they've
DM you in the past right so when he
started following you he got the
notification yeah but it was amazing
he's he's so sweet
well you know just when I thought I
couldn't love Billy anymore she goes and
does carpool karaoke and proof she's a
freaking coolest chick on the planet of
course you can count on et to bring you
all the latest Billy news so make sure
to keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]